what do batman and william shakespeare
have in common it's not a riddle just an
easter egg one of many and matt reeves
is the batman warning spoilers for the
batman ahead
the earliest action set piece in the
batman comes fairly early on beforehand
we see a gang dressed in ghoulish black
and white face makeup target a man but
before they can cause any real harm
batman emerges from the shadows ready to
lay down the hurt the hell are you
supposed to be
the gang members never provide a name
for themselves and it's possible they
only wore the face makeup because it was
halloween but it's hard not to see a few
influences on the aesthetic first and
foremost there's the mutant gang that
batman fights in frank miller's the dark
knight returns they also boasted pasty
white skin reminiscent to the gang in
the new movie plus there's the joker's
gang from batman beyond who dressed up
as their favorite super villain thanks
to a brief cameo toward the end of the
movie we know joker exists in this
universe so could he already have some
minions at his disposal it's also worth
mentioning the dc related appearance in
the gang fight scene the young kid who's
trying to become a member of the gang
who refuses to commit violence is played
by jayla kurgo who plays tim drake on
titans
while on the subject of the opening
fight those thugs apparently didn't know
who they were messing with right as
batman arrives on the scene he lays down
some perks upon being asked who he is
after laying down the hurt batman
responds in a way only batman can
inventions it's a cool line and it also
comes straight from batman the animated
series in the 1990s while one might
assume the line would come from the
pages of a comic book the first time he
actually uttered the phrase came in the
episode nothing to fear where batman
first runs into scarecrow at the end of
the storyline batman's able to overcome
his fears and in the process he lays
down the pep talk to end all pep talks
i am vengeance
i am the knight
i
am
batman
robert pattinson's batman may stop at
the first third but it's chilling to
hear him say it nonetheless
there's a lot happening during the
explosive car chase between batman and
penguin with so much going on you'd be
forgiven if you missed a quick shout out
to one of the most influential parties
of the dark knight mythos at one point
during the chase you can see a street
sign directing traffic to go somewhere
called robinson bridge this is more than
likely a reference to jerry robinson he
was a primary ghost artist for batman
comics throughout the 1940s working
closely with both bob kane and bill
finger to develop many of the central
tenets that went on to define the
character he's most often credited with
helping create robin the boy wonder he
also claimed to have created the joker
reportedly drawing the first concept
sketch for the character but bob kane
repeatedly disputed that regardless of
who created what jerry robinson was
central to defining the character with
many of his contributions still propping
up in batman adaptations to this day
it's nice to see a shout out to the
legendary artist and the latest
iteration of the character
director matt reeves is apparently quite
a big fan of the original 1966 batman tv
series prior to shooting the batman in
2018 he attended a batman 66
retrospective exhibit uploading a
plethora of photos from his visit to
twitter
that influence seems to have carried
over into the batman for starters you
can find a bust of william shakespeare
in the background of bruce wayne's
office this is an allusion to 1966's
batman where bruce wayne played by adam
west would access the bat cave through a
secret switch that he kept hidden within
a bust of you guessed it william
shakespeare but that's not all later in
the movie batman runs down the side of a
building using a cable this is another
allusion to 1966's batman as the caped
crusader and the boy wonder robin played
by burt ward would often scale the sides
of buildings using a cable
who are you
you must know in gotham city check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]